Kyrgyzstan - more than 90 per cent of the country is
mountainous,
with peaks up to 7-thousand 500 meters high.
Most Kyrgyz people live from farming
or animal husbandry.
The climate is harsh and the cuisine is - rustic.
Baking is often done in a clay oven - for
example, to produce the traditional flatbread
of the region called lepyoshka.
It's a simple snack - but an attractive one.
Flour, sugar, butter, salt and yeast make
up the dough and off it goes into the oven.
After baking for 15 minutes - the lepyoshka
are done.
They sell for around 35 cents apiece.
13 year old Rosahun delivers them to the market
every morning.
Marmur has been making them for 10 years in
this family-owned bakery.
He bakes 500 lepyoshkas a day.
It's a good business.
“People always aks for this bread for occasions like funerals or weddings.
It's a popular bread and it's a staple for
us.”
Although the bakery is a bit out of the way,
the customers always stop by to pick up their
lepyoshka - fresh from the oven.
The flatbread is served at nearly every meal
in Kyrgyzstan.
The regulars come in the morning to stock
up for the day.
“It tastes good - it's warm and it's pleasant
to eat.
I always buy the bread here because it's always
fresh.”
The bakers intend to pass on the bread recipe
to the next generation.
They're certain that lepyoshka will retain
its popularity in Kyrgyzstan for years to come.